[Music]
the spirit of self alienation has its
existence in the world of culture but
since this hole has become alienated
from itself there stands beyond that
world the unreal world of pure
consciousness or of thought its content
is in the form of pure thought and
thought is its absolute element since
however thought is in the first instance
only the element of this world
consciousness only has these thoughts
but as yet it does not think them or is
unaware that they are thoughts they
exist for consciousness in the form of
picture thoughts for it steps out of its
actual world into pure consciousness yet
is itself generally still in the sphere
of the actual world and its determinant
is the disrupted consciousness is only
in itself our implicitly the self
identity of pure consciousness a fact
that is known to us but not to itself
thus it is only the immediate elevation
of itself an elevation it is not yet
accomplished within itself and it still
has within it its opposite principle by
which it is conditioned without having
become master of it through the movement
of mediation consequently the essence of
its thought has for it the value of
essence not merely in the form of the
abstract in itself but in the form of a
common actuality of an actuality that
has merely been raised into another
element without having lost there in the
specific character of an actuality that
does not exist merely in thought it is
essential to distinguish it from the in
itself which is the essence of the stoic
consciousness what counted for the
latter was merely the form of thought as
such which besides has any alien content
taken from the actual world what counts
however for the consciousness we are
dealing with is not the form of thought
this too is essentially distinct from
the in itself of the virtuous
consciousness for which essence though
it stands in a relationship to the
actual world and is the essence of the
world itself yet is initially a non
actual essence in the consciousness
under discussion essence although lying
beyond the actual world nonetheless
counts as an actual essence in the same
way what is intrinsically right and good
in the sphere of legislative reason and
the universal that is adopted by
consciousness and testing laws these
also do not possess the character of
actuality therefore well pure thought
fell within the world of culture itself
as an aspect of the alienation that is
as the standard for judging good and bad
in the abstract
through having passed through the
process of the whole it has become
enriched with the moment of actuality
and thereby with content but this
actuality of the essence is at the same
time only in actuality of pure not of
actual consciousness although it is
raised into the element of thought it
does not yet count as a thought for this
actual consciousness rather it lies for
the latter beyond its own actuality for
it is the flight from this actuality
here in paragraph 527 Hegel is now
beginning a new and rather shorts only
11 paragraphs section of the spirit
portion of the work and this is you
might say rounding out this this this
subsection of spirits we've we've now
explored culture and the alienation that
it produced and we're moving into
something something new in a certain
respect but not entirely new as we're
gonna see in both this paragraph and in
the paragraph that follows there's a lot
of allusions that are being made to sort
of picking up the threads of earlier
discussions and yet what is being
discussed is something new in certain
respects as well and this is one of the
paragraphs where Hegel is going to
clarify it now this new section is
called faith and pure insight right
global arena einzige insight understood
in the sense of you know having insight
into the very nature of things something
that goes beyond the phenomenal world in
a certain respect although we're gonna
see we're not going to totally escape
that and then faith or belief
globba as a new comportment for the
individual consciousness and for self
consciousness remember too that what
we've got going on in the entire
phenomenology is is this development of
consciousness that is motivated
particularly as self consciousness by
the desire for recognition by a drive
for consciousness to know what it is in
relation to the world that it inhabits
here we're actually moving in a certain
sense beyond the world although we won't
truly escape it as we're going to see so
there's a lot of ground to cover let's
jump in
he says referring back to what was
happening in the previous well really
like 10 paragraphs the spirit of self
alienation has its existence in the
world of culture the that that is the
true
that we've arrived at that the the
sophisticated consciousness of culture
is a self alienated one and everybody
else in culture whether they realize it
or not their self alienated too and he
says but since this whole has become
alienated from itself
there stands beyond that world the
unreal world of pure consciousness or of
thoughts so we've got a kind of polarity
we've got the actual world of culture on
one side we've got the unreal world of
thought whether we want to call this a
world of platonic ideas or can't you
know newman 'l it's not really going to
be that it's going to be something
different but if that's where you want
to start that's perfectly fine so he
says its content is in the form of pure
thought and thought is its absolute
element so it sounds like we've really
made an advance in terms of
consciousness but Hegel points out here
that this is really just in a beginning
state where it's not truly aware of what
it's up to that's part of what we're
gonna arrive at through insight a little
bit later on so he tells us thought is
in the first instance only the element
of this world consciousness only has
these thoughts but it yet does not think
them now you might say what is he
talking about how can you have a thought
that's not thought thought as a noun
that is not being thought as I guess you
could say you know an adjective but it's
really a verb you know applying to to
that noun what is doing the thinking of
these thoughts how can you have a
thought that's not entirely being
thought that's a good question here and
Hegel is going to tell us what he means
by that by talking in terms of what's
translated here is picture thought often
translated in other places as
representation forced along a kind of
thinking that is not yet conceptual but
grief lika thinking but
making sense of things through images
maybe through complex images even images
that could be merely schemas but are not
yet concepts or notions so he tells us
consciousness does not think them or is
unaware that they are thoughts they
exist for consciousness in the form of
picture thoughts it thinks these are
good enough and it's because it steps
out of its actual world into pure
consciousness but it's generally still
in the sphere of the actual world and
it's determinate Ness
so this disrupted consciousness that is
in a certain sense transcended the
actual world of culture that has moved
beyond it to the the pure eye as Hegel
called it of a thought is still
importing content in the form of
representations or pictures or images
from that actual world into that unreal
world of thought in order to make sense
of it and it's not aware that by doing
so it's actually vitiating its own
activity so he says this disrupted
consciousness is only implicitly in
itself the self-identity of pure
consciousness it's not really developed
to the point that it needs to be and he
says now notice here we're seeing that
the phenomenologist of spirit is is
giving us a cue about what we're seeing
and what the person who's being regarded
the person at the stage of development
is not seeing he says this is a fact
that's known to us but not to itself so
we are in a certain sense in a
privileged position with respect to this
this self-consciousness that is that is
developing so he says thus it's only the
immediate elevation of itself an
elevation it is not yet accomplished
within itself and it still has within it
its opposite principle by which it is
conditioned so what is this opposite
principle by which it is
addition something that it is taking
from the actual world of culture what
does it have from the actual world of
culture well it has all of these
interesting determinations as we saw
like good and bad or noble consciousness
and ignoble consciousness or wealth and
state power or what all sorts of other
things as well and it's also bringing
its own alienation along with it and all
of this is getting ultimately transposed
into the unreal world of thought and and
here I want to pause for just a moment
and if you think about this in a more
general sense how do we this is a
problem that that Plato posed a problem
that Kant posed a problem that you know
Hegel's great adversaries although Hegel
didn't realize that he was in a rivalry
with him Schopenhauer would posed this
is a problem that the neoplatonist would
pose with many other people would would
raise how do we in fact talk about this
unreal world of thought whatever we're
happy happening to call it the the
intelligible world the neumann old world
how do we talk about it without using
some of the language some of the schemas
some of the experiences some of the
metaphors some of the ideas stemming
from the actual world that we do in fact
inhabit and which has as Hegel saying
conditioned our very consciousness in
the 20th century we became very aware
although this is not something that was
not already known so much by great 19th
century thinkers and people even before
them but it became very clear within the
world of philosophy just how much the
metaphors that we used that we're taking
essentially from the world how much
those metaphors affect what we think
transcends the world so enough of a
little digression they're coming back he
says consequently the essence of its
thought the the raison alright the the
thing that's most important in its
thought has for it the value of essence
not merely in the form of the
abstract in itself but in the for me
says of a common actuality something
that is actual something that is real
something again that's being taken from
the world an actuality that's merely
been raised into another element without
having lost their in the specific
character of an actuality that does not
exist merely in thought here existing
merely in thought is actually a higher
qualification a good thing and you could
say that this consciousness doesn't
quite grasp that it needs to leave more
stuff behind now here is where Hegel is
going to give us some really interesting
contrasts to three previous stages of
the dialectic one of them coming from
the self consciousness section two of
them coming from the reason section what
does he tell us
so the first contrast he says is with
the in itself which is the essence of
stoic consciousness so this is very
important he's saying what's going on
here is not the same thing although it
is similar to what was going on in the
development of the stoic consciousness
way back in the self consciousness
section what's the difference he says
what counted for the stoic consciousness
was merely the form of thought itself it
was withdrawing into a kind of you know
as we call it the inner citadel which
was the form of thought it was
retreating from the world and according
to Hegel he says which besides has any
alien content taken from the actual
world there was content coming in but
stoicism according to Hegel couldn't
really in effect make sense of that
right and it was it it's it's talked
about the rational the good the true
turned out to be kind of empty so he
says over here it's not the form of
thought that were particularly
interested and he says this
is essentially a distinct right he says
what counselor this consciousness is not
the form of thought so what what is it
that we're interested in let's look at
the second contrast he brings up the
virtuous consciousness so this is from
the section virtue and the way of the
world that we discovered in the reason
section right the reason portion of the
work towards the end of it if you
remember virtue appeared to have the
victory at first but then it turned out
that it was kind of empty and couldn't
stand up against the way of the actual
world so he calls it then a non actual
essence and he says this this
consciousness here the consciousness of
faith and ultimately an insight is
distinct from the in itself of the
virtuous consciousness for which essence
though it stands in a relationship to
the actual world and is the essence of
the actual world itself is initially a
non actual essence so it says in the
consciousness that we're talking about
even though essence lies beyond the
actual world it nonetheless is an actual
essence so we're using actuality here in
two different ways virtue was a non
actual essence right here we have an
actual essence in the unreal world of
thought ok so that's an interesting
distinction what about the third one ok
so here he says what is intrinsically
right or good in the sphere of
legislative reason and now when he's
saying what is intrinsically right or
good he's really not just talking about
legislative reason that's what all of
these were trying to find stoicism
virtuous consciousness they were all
grappling with what is intrinsically
right or good so that the self
consciousness could indeed embody and be
in touch with what is intrinsically
right or good so going back to this
legislative reason reason giving laws to
itself reason discovering laws he says
what is intrinsically right or good in
the sphere of legislative reason and the
universal that is adopted by
consciousness
testing laws these also don't possess
the character of actuality so notice
that in each case what is the
distinctive thing here this has
actuality an actuality that is taking
from the actual world and bringing into
its unreal world of thought and thereby
giving that unreal world of thought some
sort of actuality what kind of actuality
the actuality given by picture thinking
by horse telling alright so going on he
says while pure thought fell within the
world of culture itself is an aspect of
the alienation that is as the standard
for judging good and bad in the abstract
through having passed through the
process of the whole the whole in the
world of culture it has become enriched
something new has happened it has become
enriched with the moments of actuality
and thereby with its content so this is
going to raise some some issues he says
this actuality the essence is at the
same time only the actuality of pure and
out of actual consciousness so there's
already kind of a bifurcation taking
place here although it's raised he says
into the elements of thought it does not
yet count as a thought for this actual
consciousness rather it lies for the
latter beyond its own actuality for it
is the flight from the sexuality Hegel
saying that there's a misrecognition
taking place here on the part of the
consciousness poised in between these
two worlds it thinks that it's going
somewhere you can say not realizing that
it has already put out there the where
to which it is going in this unreal
world of thought so how is this gonna
play itself out well we have to look now
at the next ten paragraphs
religion for it is obviously religion
that we are speaking about in the form
in which it appears here is the faith
belonging to the world of culture does
not yet appear as it is in and for
itself we have already seen it in other
characteristic forms for for instance as
the unhappy consciousness as a shape of
the insubstantial process of
consciousness itself it made its
appearance - in the ethical substance as
faith in the underworld though
consciousness of the departed spirit is
strictly speaking not faith not essence
posited in the element of pure
consciousness beyond the actual world
but has itself an immediate presence
that its element is the family here
however religion in part has proceeded
from the substance and is the pure
consciousness of it in part this pure
consciousness is alienated from its
actual consciousness the essence from
its existence true it is thus no longer
the insubstantial process of
consciousness but it still has the
characteristic of an antithesis to
actuality as this actuality in general
and of an antithesis to
self-consciousness in particular it is
therefore essentially merely a belief
here now in this shorter paragraph
number 528 the second in this new
section Hegel is introducing a few more
distinctions between the phase that
we're now in and some some dialectics of
earlier phases within the phenomenology
and telling us a little bit more about
what's going on with this this
consciousness of the new section there's
the shape that it takes on the gestalt
that we're looking at and it tells us
here that we're really looking at
religion we're looking at the religion
that is the faith the globba belonging
to the world of culture a world that
we've understood now as alienating as
alienated in which self-consciousness
finds itself to be that way either
you know as a surprise because it should
have known better or because it's this
jaded self-consciousness that finds that
out and then it somehow goes beyond that
into what we're calling here faith or
belief so he says religion in the form
in which it appears here is the faith
belonging to the world of culture does
not yet appear as it is in and for
itself was a very important point the
religious consciousness Hegel thinks
that religion is really just one step
down from philosophy that religion is
really important in the development of
consciousness and you know you know
those who who don't have any sort of
religious beliefs or are hostile to
religious beliefs you might actually at
this point look at Hegel you're like ah
you know he just he was still stuck in
the the Middle Ages or the you know the
mindset of the 17th 18th early 19th
century didn't understand that we're
we're inhabiting a secular world no
Hegel totally understood that and yet at
the same time and besides you can also
say oh you know religion this and this
and this is a problem here and you know
people are they
and that religions as bad Hegel could
say totally understand
I totally get that as a matter of fact
I've talked about that before in say the
unhappy consciousness but Hegel does
think that this this drive towards the
religious and not just in the sort of
fuzzy you know we're all on the same
page kind of sense the Hegel totally
doesn't buy that but in a determinate
historical condition sense plays an
important role so we want to think about
where we might actually see religion or
the religious consciousness appearing as
it is in and for itself and the answer
is well we've got to get through you
know quite a bit more of spirit and then
we're going to get into the penultimate
section of the book which is called
religion and even there it's going to be
working itself through all these
different shapes before it gets to the
the final form the absolute religion so
Hegel now brings up two contrasts to
tell us what kind of religion we're
talking about he says we've already seen
it in other characteristic forms we've
already seen religion in characteristic
forms so what that means is that we're
not looking at religion as such religion
the only way it can possibly be or a
religion in its absolute essence here
but religion in one of the possible
shapes that it can have we've looked at
two of these shapes actually we've
looked at more than that over the course
of this but but these are the main ones
that that Hagel has talked about so far
the unhappy consciousness you remember
that was a very long section at the end
of the self consciousness portion after
stoicism after skepticism we talked
about what historical manifest
manifestations that might take so he
says the unhappy consciousness was a
shape of the insubstantial process of
consciousness itself what does he mean
there you know the the process of
consciousness consciousness itself was
pushing projecting a absolute beyond
itself and then trying to relate itself
as the the particular to it in some way
we talked about this in terms of the
eternal for example and the change
or the you know the God and the human
being or pick pick whatever you like and
this could take place through you know
worship this could take place through
prayer this could take place through all
sorts of means but it had the same
dynamic over and over and over again she
also talked about the faith in the
underworld that we saw earlier in the
spirit section when we were talking
about you know the development to the
Greek and Roman city-states and we got
into the discussion of you know the
Antigone and and all of that and Hegel
says yeah okay that's that's religion
too but that's
he says the ethical substance is faith
in the underworld through consciousness
of the depart the consciousness of the
departed spirit is strictly speaking
that faith not essence posited in the
elements of pure consciousness beyond
the actual world so this was not beyond
the actual world the underworld isn't an
extra world it's part of this world and
it was known through its immediate
presence as he said in the family right
here we're talking about something that
is different than than both of those it
is viewed as leading us into a different
world something that is transcendent so
he says here a religion and part is
proceeded from the substance and is the
pure consciousness of substance pure
consciousness of substance now pure
consciousness of substance in the sense
of like hey what does everything made of
right matter or you know you see uh you
know or something like that we're not
doing metaphysics as such here pure
consciousness of the substance as that
which has ultimate importance the
ethical substance which is also the
object of religion here Hegel says
something really interesting following
this up he says in part this pure
consciousness is alienated from its
actual consciousness the essence from
its existence there's there's a
long-standing issue of the
distinction between essence and
existence of things and traditionally
there was one being for whom its essence
was its existence or its existence is
its essence and that's God now you know
if you listen to the Thomas they will
tell this story in which there really
wasn't any distinction between essence
and existence until Thomas clarified
this this up for us and the High Middle
Ages
that's a bit of an oversimplification I
think but Hegel is way on the other end
of that and this essence existence
distinction is has already become a
long-standing part of our vocabulary now
he also talks about eight about an
antithesis right Gagen Zots in this case
so he says here we go true it thus no
longer it is thus no longer the
insubstantial process of consciousness
but it still has the characteristic of
an antithesis an opposition a setting
itself or expressing itself in
opposition to what to actuality and now
notice that Hegel says actuality in two
different ways the actuality in general
might be understood as the actuality of
the world and of an antithesis to
self-consciousness in particular so
consciousness is having an opposition
within it to self-consciousness and here
he says it is thus essentially a belief
so why that conclusion it is thus
essentially a belief a Globa well
because something is being believed in
as you might say the escape route as the
transcendent as something beyond all of
this so this over here is quite
different than the unhappy consciousness
or faith in the underworld these are
different distinct ways in which
religion develops
you